I'll feel hardline sir you guys
obviously had a bunch of leaky leaks
happen in earlier in a month but
yesterday we finally got to see you guys
unveiled battlefield hardline and for
folks who might have missed the
conference what is this new type of
battlefield because it seems like a
completely new type of battlefield well
Danny it's it's our take it visceral on
the great you know formula battlefield
and we're bringing cops and criminals to
the battlefield this time yeah it looks
like a quite an incredible warzone I
don't think I've seen a bank robbery
quite like it and for the folks who may
who might have seen that demo explained
the sort of scale how many players we
talking about it what's the sort of
moment-to-moment action in battlefield
hardline so in our press conference we
unveiled a video that showed a 32 player
match in high smoke where the criminals
are trying to get out get away with the
loot so they take out this armored truck
and they're trying to grab the loot out
of the armored truck and take it to an
extraction point and the cops are trying
to prevent that from happening so the
maps actually in downtown LA right here
where was Tara I heard cop cars go past
my hotel last night I was gonna freaked
out by it I was like yeah it's kind of
cool and it's really fun because the
setting actually provides a lot of
opportunity for players to play around
with some of our new gadgets like our
zipline and grappling hook because the
map has a lot of cool verticality to it
so yeah you know we've got some neat
traversal gadgets that really help and
pay off in the map sure here we see some
gameplay that you guys have put out
there as well and it seems like that
crazy cops and robbers thing you imagine
as a child in your head but just maybe a
little bit more extreme and the type of
vehicles that are at play in a city are
very different to why you get in a
battlefield where these are like
specific military vehicles created for a
specific tactical purpose and what type
of vehicles can you use in battlefield
hardline well Danny we actually put a
lot of emphasis on making sure that we
retain the authenticity that you expect
from battlefield so we have that armored
attack truck that you see in the video
there that's actually something that the
police use and you know we we were
amazed when we started digging into the
level of armament and weaponry that the
police force is actually
have ya you know whenever you see like a
full-scale kind of situation occur where
SWAT comes in it's pretty neat to see
what they kind of unveil they've got all
kinds of stuff from helicopters to
attack trucks like that
and of course you know criminals have
ways of getting their hands on high-end
weaponry as well so what you see in the
game is stuff that actually you know the
police force does have access to yeah
but I guess eluding tonight like talking
about that there is a certain point
where you guys as like creators of a
video game just kind of have to stop and
protect you know staying in line with
what reality is because if in reality if
there was a bank heist like that
that's that'd be pretty crazy bank heist
like Scott you know cranes falling down
and whatnot
like at what stage view guys as creators
of games just think you know what we
have touchstones in reality but we want
to make this fun well ultimately Danny
it's all about fun so we're gonna do
whatever it takes to provide a great
canvas for players to be creative inside
of and actually have fun and we want to
let players make the fun themselves and
that's what's so amazing about the
Battlefield franchise it's just that
that sandbox style of gameplay you get
in multiplayer it's it's amazing when
you watch all the videos online there's
only in battlefield moments where you
see people just you know piling up c4
and launching tanks up into the air and
it's really amazing how creative people
can be so we want to provide a backdrop
for them to have that fun in that
creativity in terms of level design
disposes a lot of new challenges that
perhaps military battlefield games
wouldn't and what type of levels should
we be used to seeing in hardline well
right now we've got our high tension map
and we'll be unveiling other maps
throughout the rest of the campaign as
we lead up to launch on October 21st but
I will say this we have a variety of
different settings it's not all gonna be
urban like the high-tension map you'll
you'll get to experience some organic
maps as well and a lot of neat locations
well and the single-player as well has
been alluded to and some of the trainers
have seen as well and will it be in line
with other battlefield games will it be
a shortened single-player campaign but
the emphasis is on the multiplayer side
well it's really important for us at
visceral to deliver a fun and compelling
single-player experience you guys have a
good history of yeah that's kind of what
we
doing and that was what was so exciting
when we teamed up with with the dice
guys to talk about this idea they were
excited about what we could bring to a
single player so yeah we definitely have
plans to make sure we deliver a really
fun and engaging campaign we'll be
talking about that more next month but
for now we're really excited about this
crazy beta that we just launched yeah so
you launched the beta yesterday and in
keeping with Battlefield tradition some
people would say Origen took a bit of a
punch to the chin is that is that a kind
of a in one sort of weird way is that
like a mark of like happiness that you
guys there's so much anticipation for
the game that you manage to like create
that much buzz around it that it sort of
took down the framework a little bit
well Danny to be honest you know we want
our players to have a flawless
experience at all times and you know
it's unfortunate that some of the some
of the networks that the game was on had
some issues when when all the people
went to sign up so you know ideally they
don't have those problems and we want to
make sure that the players have a great
time from the second they try to engage
with our game and that's exactly why we
were doing this beta we want you know we
want to learn from the community what we
can do to improve the game we've got
more time before we have to finish the
game so we want to get that feedback and
bring it in and address issues that they
may find and make sure we have a really
stable and fun launch for people so yeah
I mean it was a bummer that that those
issues happen but you know this is gonna
be a learning experience for us a
visceral and we really ultimately just
want to deliver a great game for players
how much responsibility do you guys have
a visceral for that type of stuff
because presumably a lot of it is out of
your hands
via bit dices framework or with
Electronic Arts who are actually running
a lot of that sort of stuff well hey
listen the way I look at it is we're all
one big team so whenever anything
happens it's it's all of ours you know
I'm gonna own all of it so yeah I mean
it's just that it's you know we're one
team one company and you know there were
some some challenges but you know what
everybody reacted quickly
I think there's tons of people playing
yeah and hopefully everybody is ok now
well let's talk about the modes you
talked about heist mode we saw and I
load it out on the stage show yesterday
can you talk about some of the other
modes that are playable to hardline in
the way they change just the core
gameplay of PAL trailer alone sure so
the other mode that we're actually
letting people
experience right now is Blood Money okay
that's a symmetric symmetrical game-mode
where there's a giant pile of cash in
the middle of the mat that the cops are
trying to recover as evidence and the
criminals are trying to get to you
because hey they want money so that's
kind of the focus they're kind of
rushing to that pile of money each team
actually has their own vault where they
have to collect the money and bring that
money back to you
so you know the mission the goal is to
get as much money as you can and win the
match now what's really cool about that
mode is if you're all of a sudden losing
because one team's just loading up their
vault yeah you can do an end-around go
to their vault and steal the money out
see these scores just drastically shift
and it provides a lot of cool choke
points in terms of like engagement areas
where people are having really good
shootouts but it also lets you kind of
tip the balance quickly so you're never
really out of the match I saw as we had
to look at it a couple of weeks ago a
GameSpot as well and I love the fact
that your truck actually physically
fills up with money as you're collecting
it and headed you as well when you when
you're running running with the money
your bag is almost there's almost like a
trail like of money coming out of the
back of the vehicle or the bag that you
have and is that is uh purely for a we
want we want somebody to know that guy's
got money yeah this is fun
right I like to see that trail of money
and yeah I mean it's it's an indicator
right we've worked a lot on messaging
and accessibility and making sure that
people kind of know what to do
throughout the various game modes and
you know that was just a clear
identifier of hey this guy's got cash
cuz of course if you shoot him he drops
the cash you can pick that up but the
other thing you could do Danny is you
shoot that guy he drops the cash you can
hang back wait for his friend shoot him
alright so I mean there's a lot of a lot
of cool gameplay that we get out of that
excellence and that there seems to be a
lot of new equipment to that end as well
you've got the grapple hook ieveis if
line as well I could you explain how
they sort of change up how players will
attack different objectives yeah sure so
one of the other things we're trying to
do in a high-tension map and throughout
all the multiplayer maps is provide
opportunities for verticality whether
you want to you know scale all the way
up to the top of the crane or if you
want to go camp out on a roof but the
grappling hook helps you out
right so you
the grappling hook to get up on a roof
and then the zipline is just really fun
because it provides really quick first
movement from place to place so you can
scale up to the top of one of these big
giant downtown skyscrapers and then
zipline to the next one across the way
so that's really fun and again we want
to make sure that players not only have
great traversal on the on the ground
plane but we want to allow for
verticality so so those particular
gadgets really help with that yeah and
it seemed like you were trying to
emphasize that in yesterday's trailer as
well that was quite a lot of up-and-down
movement another thing that you showed
off in the trailer was the LEvolution we
have come to expect from battlefield
games and in in some of the older games
it has sort of some people have
criticized it as being a a each level
has that one thing that always falls
down how are you guys attacking and
evolution and visceral considering like
that is a sort of a known quantity at
this stage well as gamers when we sat
down to actually start designing these
ideas we wanted to make sure that we
didn't just do things that were cool to
look at yeah wanted those things to
actually have an impact on what the
player and players had to do and the
play space so we really just took more
of a holistic approach to hey if we're
gonna do something like this giant crane
collapse what are the advantages that
you get out of doing it right it's not
about taking things away it's about
providing new opportunities and new
inventive ways for players to play so
when that crane comes down you create
for the if you're on the police side for
instance it creates a great vantage
point if you want to keep an eye on the
bag locations in heists yeah it also
creates a great traversal path for the
criminals when they're trying to do a
quick getaway so we really put that at
the forefront of what we're doing when
we have something happen in the map
whether it's a small scale kind of event
of destruction or something big like
that crane you want players to feel like
there's an incentive and a reason to do
it not just to have cool visual effects
yeah but to actually have some kind of
tactical advantage I mean that's really
what battlefield battlefields about
being tactical creating opportunities
for yourself playing as a team yeah and
in the trailer we saw a lot of really
good teamwork
the reality of battlefield is that
sometimes that sort of teamwork doesn't
happen the people who don't know each
other are on random servers and they're
not encouraged to work as a team how are
you guys official gonna try and create
modes and
levels that encourage a type of
cooperation yeah so we're doing a bunch
of different things some of the stuff
we're doing on kind of the squad side is
you know stuff as simple ads when you're
running with your squad you run faster
okay
when you go up to a guy that's got a
pack on his back let's say he's got a
medic pack now you could just run up to
him instead of like yelling at the guy
hey drop of medic pack for me drop medic
yeah you just go up to him hit the
action key and then all of a sudden
you're getting healed we're doing things
to allow players to get what they want
out of the game right we don't want to
force them to play as a team if they
don't want you because hey we realize
some people either maybe don't want to
yeah or just don't know how to yet
because it can be a little intimidating
when you first get into battlefield I
mean there's such a legacy so many
people have been playing it for so long
so we want to ease that accessibility
let people get in there but ultimately
won't we want to reward for team mate
for team play we don't want to punish
for not doing it
I want to reward you for doing it well
I'm gonna I was very mean and didn't
that go to the chat too often cuz I had
so many selfish questions myself as a
massive fan base is asking our weapons
unlock like usual or they purchase from
money that you get in matches a new
class a so what what is this twit icon
winner I don't know what that is I think
it's him standing in front of the mirror
taking a selfie
you're doing a weird 0b alright black
Black Mesa hey check it out your
question is our weapons unlock like
usual are they purchased for money one
in game matches yes they are purchased
with money brilliant in game matches you
can kind of jump around we don't have
that same level progression that you've
seen in past battlefield yeah and we do
actually use cash and again that's
another thing that we're focused on
which is allow players to pick and
choose what they want we're not locking
you into one progression hat to go
through this entire weapon progression
hey if you want to jump to a different
gun and as soon as you got that cash you
can go ahead and jump down to it now
another thing we're doing Danny that's
pretty cool is we're gonna have this
idea of weapon licenses right so you're
not only going to have the ability to
you know pick the the weapons that you
like within an individual class but
let's say you played one class and you
really loved the weapon in that class
but you know you you're the kind of
person who wants to unlock everything
you can buy a weapon license for it so
for me I really like the p90
I can buy a p90 weapon license and then
go play the professional
diaper and I could use that weapon if I
want to cool so we're doing a lot of
things to encourage replayability
experimentation and letting players pick
and choose the way they want to play
excellence Tifa boots it's pistol games
thank you so much for coming on are
quite the talker I always love talking
to you bouncing hardline for the folks
at home and when is it out on on web
platforms without October 21st no I'm
just messing with ya October 21st in
North America
October 23rd over in Europe and I think
it's the 24th in the UK sweet Steve
thank you very much again and we'll be
back on the GameSpot stage pretty soon
with Batman and Lego Batman 3 but first
we're gonna check out some Super Smash
Bros